à vous vous avez trouvé l'amour sur le
plateau avec flavie flament chanson
exactement en chansons vous delphine est
ce que ça vous n'êtes jamais ça vous est
déjà effleuré l'esprit
mais savez vous rendez compte
une personne n'est sûr que kannad donc
un français sur quatre on m'a dit je
n'envisage une relation avec des
collègues jean-michel vous l'envié aux
usagers a déjà fait des dizaines de fous
moi franchement c'est normal mais dans
l'otc nommément on est huit heures du
matin jusqu'à 22h 21h 36m boulot on est
forcément c'est là notre travail a pas
mis six noms mais dans ma tête je veux
dire quoi qu'en dise vous ça vous a déjà
effleuré l'esprit
non parce que je suis indépendant
journée ça démarre donc je travaille de
chez moi
difficile de l'âme soeur il voulait plus
aucun moment on dit me disent oui oui
possible
non non et non il fait pas ça alors
qu'il volait pas les choses on a bien
sûr il va y aller mais alors est-ce
qu'on peut le savoir maintenant vous lui
avez mis un bon pas c'est plus rare au
sein de la vérité c'est tout les deux me
défendre mérité la vérité c'est elle qui
m'a mis un vent que moi qui lui met un
vent moi ça va bien sûr j'étais fini les
vacances et des noms dans le travail là
ici là depuis que tu es là il y en a
combien qui tombe draguer a franchement
on aurait dit le franchement on s'en bat
jamais à toi tu as la bonne cuisine sur
ces huit toi m'a dit m'a étonné y
compris les techniciens et tous et pas
de sécurité ne t'a pas draguer dans
l'équipe personne ne m'attendait ci est
en fait personne moi c'est vrai nom
était personnelle dans l'équipe personne
vous voulez votre machine non cash et
orléans bleus montrent pas alors voilà
comment la regarde
ah oui alors il ya bernard montiel et
mathieu de lambeaux à quelques pas qui
font pas tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]